carried carefully from the ancient
archives of the Palace of Westminster
the act of parliament that's caused all
the fuss here it is in black and white
the document that brought us together
that tied the knot that formalized the
marriage that has seldom been easy and
sometimes been loveless what did this
actually mean for Britain and Europe
this is the European communities act of
1972 which took us into Europe and its
passage proved almost as difficult and
almost as toxic and brexit is proving to
be because it's subordinated Britain to
a superior legal order the European
communities so going in was as difficult
as coming out is proving to be
absolutely the motion to take us in was
won by 112 votes which looked
comfortable but it was won by Prime
Minister Ted Heath who was a
conservative because 69 Labour MPs
defected and joined him in voting for
the motion now to reason may well I
suspect have no such luxury from the
early 60s when French president de
Gaulle didn't want us in it's been a
fraught relationship we have the charm
of new great no fracturing parties
Europe the great explosive issue the
European Union as Britain versus Europe
a referendum on Britain's membership of
the European Union and dividing a nation
brexit means brexit in truth it's always
been difficult they've seen us and we
saw ourselves as outsiders but one man
then Tory Prime Minister Edward Heath
long had a vision and it was this your
single greatest political achievement
presumably would be taking Britain into
the ears of them was well I think that's
what historians will say and I'll do it
because it is the longest historical
factor the action what's followed has
tested parliamentary friendships though
against the odds this one survived euro
foul Ken Clark a whip for Ted Heath in
72 and bill cash
the MP Clark's called the most
Euroskeptic of all your joy at leaving
the European Union just try and sum it
up well we get back democratic
self-government so the people of this
country in general elections can vote
for a government that represents what
they wanted and in addition to that it
means that we then have what I hope to
be a much more successful and prosperous
economy because we'll be deciding the
laws and not the European Union right so
you're saying good riddance to the Act
you will mourn its passing well there's
a certain ironic symmetry to my career
that looks there my last Parliament's
getting to the one in which we might we
are going to leave I feel really sad I
think it's bizarre that what I see is
the collapse of confidence in the
political system and angry protests from
disappointed people who whom the modern
world isn't treating them too well and
it is is taking us out you know a wave
of angry emotion whatever happens to
brexit whatever happens to political
friendships this document will hopefully
survive in the archives for centuries
testimony to a time in history when
Britain agonized over what sort of
country it should be